infrastructure
and american competitiveness and what
we're going to do to
make sure we once again lead the world
across the board and infrastructure it
not only creates jobs but it makes us a
lot more competitive
around the world if you have the best
infrastructure in the world
we're going to be talking about that and
i welcome all my colleagues here and
thank you all for coming on in thank you
[Music]
[Music]
i've been talking to a lot of my
republican friends in the house and the
senate continue to do that
and uh and we have we met
have a number of meetings with
republicans on the
coronavirus bill and uh house senate
combination of both so we're keeping
everybody informed
are you comfortable with having to limit
the direct payments
are you comfortable with having to limit
the direct payments
comfortable with having to limit the
direct payments yes
what do you say to the 12 million
americans who won't receive checks
anymore
thank you all for you
um
you